hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday June 8th 2020 what's going on how
are ya how you guys doing how you
holding up you're doing all right you
stay enough to social media there you're
not watching the news I hope you are I
hope you staying off it you watch too
much of it it gets you in your brain it
starts to eat away your brain next thing
you know you're out there riding on your
bicycle attack and a couple of [__]
13-year old chicks and a Google I don't
some teenage boy for hanging up sides at
a park oh do I want to make fun of that
guy I want to make fun of that guy but I
can't you know I am that guy I wouldn't
do that to those kids but I do that I
just did it to a smoke detector you know
I just screamed I got it you [__]
[__] at a smoke detector that would not
stop beeping and I tried everything I
took the battery out
I changed the battery I hit the reset
button I held it down for 10 seconds I
held it down for 15 seconds I held it
down for 10 seconds and then hit it
again I held it down for 15 to 20
seconds and then hit it again I took the
whole [__] thing off unplugged it it
was still beeping I went I went down to
the [__] fuse box and shut off the
power in that [__] room because I've
wanted to do my podcast in that room so
I wouldn't be too loud and wake up the
kids right and it still would not stop
[__] beeping I literally I just had
to call a [__] repairman to come over
here because I got I got some press to
do this week Oh Billy Hollywood Oh Billy
Hollywood okay history from the guy
right here he suspects it's an old smoke
detector that needs to your place if you
can send a photo or if they can try to
pick up a replacement now for [__] sakes
I'm not out there you Mother's
what the [__] was the name of the thing
some sort of fast alert the [__] was it
called and I went into [__] chat
rooms and I was talking to robots that
were acting like they were people and
then they told me if I gave him a dollar
like some [__] stripper they tell me
what I needed to do [__] unbelievable
come on where the hell is it
smoke flash alert all right
I'll write this to it it's a flash alert
smoke detector oh man I was yelling at
this [__] thing I was yelling at it
and I got to try to find a [__]
picture one he's just [__] can you
send a picture of it what I say fast
alert isn't what I just said
anyway I have a big week this week so I
need to use my [__] office to do this
to the zoom roam chats whatever you call
it and there it is there it is Miss
America but bought a puppet but a puppet
baa alright let's see if I can take a
[__] screen shows is this technically
even a [__] podcast anymore so you
guys listening to me ordering a [__]
new smoke detector now come on
why won't you why won't you why won't
you why why of course of course why why
would you let me take a [__] picture
of it you [__] there it is
alright see that I always think there's
no solution immediately immediately is
my first thought there's no solution
nobody's gonna hear me I don't feel
loved and act like a big [__] baby
over over and over absolutely nothing um
there we go
there we go all right I'll taken care of
yeah so I [__] flipped out on this I
flipped out on this thing I made that
guy in the bicycle look like a sane
human being that poor bastard I you know
he's 60 years old
okay he's set in his ways okay he likes
the America he grew up in okay where a
cop kid put his knee on the neck of so
buddy who isn't white until they die and
it's not murder it's called good police
work nine minutes by the way every time
I hear more details on that [__]
thing how fascinating is it that people
are still arguing that what that cop did
wasn't wrong you know it's just like all
right let's say your brother had a
counterfeit $20 bill or whatever the
[__] this guy was charged with and let's
say he was a problem when they tried to
arrest him once they have him face down
and he's handcuffed behind his [__]
back and the guy's got his knee on the
back of his neck all right he gave him
the business a little bit the guys like
I can't breathe I can't breathe you let
him up certainly when he stopped he's
asking for his mother and then stops
making any noise for a full three
minutes that guy just straight-up
[__] murdered that guy and is a
monster and I find it hard to believe
that anybody who was with them didn't
know exactly what the [__] he was doing
I don't know [__] about the anatomy or
how the body works but I know when you
do something like that if the guy
stopped Taibbi I let him up let him up
it's over yeah and I also know that not
all cops are like that most cops are not
like that so this is not a cop thing
this is a that guy thing and the guys
that he was with you need to get them
out of there
because what cops do when they do the
job right is [__] they're heroes
you got some lunatic coming into your
[__] house they come in to get the
guy out do you want to do that job I
don't wanna [__] do that job I don't
pull somebody over at four o'clock in
the [__] morning and get worried
about getting run over by an 18-wheeler
forget about what the [__] this guy has
in his car so you know you just got to
get the bad guys out of that they can't
think CAF's be held accountable you
cannot have people because they have a
[__] badge walking around just
[__] murdering people so anyway let's
get back to old fatso on the bike which
I don't think is that fat cause he's 60
years old although I will tell you like
Madonna he's way too old to be wearing
those clothes at some point people you
got to Dress your age all right you got
to put on something people do not need
to know how much exactly how many pounds
you need to lose okay okay there's a
reason for
that shaming okay nobody wants to look
at it yeah I just think that that guy is
just watched but he's also in Bethesda
Maryland so he's right outside of DC so
he might've he might be some lobbyist I
have no idea I think he's just too close
to the game you know what I mean it's
like if if he ever go to sit if you ever
like film something that you made right
am I the world that Amin you write a
script and then you do it it always
looks like it sucks
you know you're just like you can never
you can't gauge it cuz you have you
can't just watch it cuz you knew
everything that happened that day
everything that's on the cutting room
floor all that you can't like objective
objectively look at it and I think
people who just watched too much news
social media or if they they work in
politics I think just after a while you
just get [__] jaded like last night I
was watching my new favorite show there
that one with Amanda Peet and Christian
Slater there for some reason it's got
the weirdest [__] name ever I think
it's it's something that's like dirty
James Betty or psyche I mean I've
watched a bunch of episodes I still
don't know the name of the [__] show
but I can tell you this Amanda Peet's
one of the best actors I've ever [__]
seen how did that pertain to what the
[__] I was just talking about I don't
know I don't know what the hell I was
trying to say there was a thought there
there was a thought and it went away so
anyway I got such a [__] kick out of
watching that [__] guy in that
bicycle he did everything but growl at
those kids you know the other kid Jesus
Christ the last kid the guy he should
have done something you know I mean but
then it's like it's [__] 60 year old
guy what are you supposed to do you know
you know what you
Pedro Martinez showed you what you do
when someone of a certain age comes at
you you back up you put your hands up
you say you don't want to do it and at
the last second if he keeps coming at
you you gotta grab by his big old
pumpkin head and just send him down to
the grass there was plenty of ferns and
[__] bushes there for this guy to
land and that's what he should have done
do you know and as much as everybody's
coming down on this guy in the bicycle I
gotta be honest with you I don't think
that that last kid was raised right he
didn't defend those girls on earth and
he allowed this old guy to [__] and run
him over and you know it's like at some
point you got to be the young lion
that's gonna be taking over the pride
okay this guy had plenty of white hair
and whatever was left of his [__]
lion's mane and this kid just he just
didn't get the job done that's what it
is and I know we live in an era now we
handle everybody with like little
[__] velvet gloves and you tell
everybody well you know the fact that
you were there just voicing your
disapproval was enough it really wasn't
enough it wasn't enough the guy is
coming at you he's 60 years old he's got
those stupid [__] I write a [__]
Tour de France bike shoes on you know
the dumb ones were your [__] feet
lock into the pedals what kind of a
[__] [__] who's not in a bike race
puts those things on I'll tell you what
kind of a [__] [__] the same kind
of a [__] [__]
that goes to a sporting event and is
wearing almost an entire Jersey like
some [__] jerk-off who goes to a
football game he's got everything on but
the [__] helmet
I get it you're riding a bicycle I I
still do not understand why you can't
ride a bike with sweatpants at a t-shirt
I know you can but like where did that
go that okay now I'm working out
everybody who [__] works out now they
got you got to dress like a [__]
x-men booth from some [__] spider-man
suit on does that help you lift better
you can can you pick up more weight is
that what it is everybody walking around
with the [__] sports bra your [__]
stomach out [__] tight ass shorts up
your ass you're making a porno oh yeah
you're working out
it's their [__] bodies they [__]
what yeah I mean [__] broken toes are
there in gyms every year cuz somebody
drops a [__] dumbbell on their foot
cuz they're too busy looking at the
[__] tits and ass walking by [__]
Wonder Woman wall more clothes than half
these broads who go to the [__]
goddamn gym and now the guys are
following suit
he saw that [__] marshmallow he had
no business wearing those [__]
clothes but anyway getting back to what
I was saying it was that that [__]
dude in the end should have taken it you
heard him guy clip-clopping like some
[__] horse that lost a shoe coming at
him gritting his [__] teeth I mean
that guy right there that guy Majan that
guy if he was a [__] cop Jesus Christ
control your [__] emotions from the
guy who [__] called a smoke detector
a [__] today I did that I did that Dober
father of two you know experiencing the
miracle for the second time being at
home just you know and you know if you
saw what I did this morning the fact
that what I did this morning and skin
calling a smoke detector a [__] [__]
can actually happen on the [__] same
day it's just you know it's really a
testament to why none of you should be
listening to this [__] podcast unless
you're just doing it because you want to
feel better about yourselves this
morning I had to take my lovely wife and
my son over to the doctor make sure
everything was all right which we did
then afterwards my wife told me that she
was hungry so we hit this burger stand
one of our favorite burger stands in LA
right just absolutely delicious and we
were just sitting there afterwards and
we were eating these burgers right and
the guy in front of me Oh Pete popped
his trunk it was sitting in his trunk
with his legs hanging out eating the
burger was hilarious and he saw me
looking at him he laughed and I left it
was like you know cuz all didn't they
got all the [__] table the picnic
tables and [__] I roped off with the
police tape you can't sit there right so
I brought the burgers over and I just
sat in the car
you know my son was you know I just you
know breastfed and all that so he was
full and he was sleeping we were just
sitting in the car eating burgers fries
and I had a Fanta orange and just took
me back to when I was a kid because I
was thinking like this is what my
parents used to do like that and and
this is perfect is we used to go out and
we drive around or whatever then we
would go to McDonald's or some [__] like
daddy get all the kids get cheeseburgers
small fried chocolate shake
was the same order for all my siblings
and then they get and it was two Big
Macs two large fries two large cokes and
we would just sit there and eat it it
was like the [__] best it was the
best and I was sitting there what today
it took me back to that the early 70s
early to mid 70s when I was you know I
guess five six years old maybe and just
all the neighborhood's I kids just were
outside playing riding bikes being
jealous of this kids bike down the
street he had the [__] Apollo 5 speed
and me and my older brother just like
was so envious of it it looked like a
[__] motorcycle and we had the look
that up Apollo 5 speed it had like the
FATA back tire the skinnier front I look
like a chopper right it was just the
Quinn had the [__] shifter on it the
stop it was just the coolest [__]
bike we just had regular coast of bikes
and you know it was just dogs running
around
none of them on leash leashes and [__]
you know this is before like to catch a
predator just [__] scared the [__]
out of everybody and just took me back
to that simple [__] time and I was
just like this is it this is what it's
all about I spent all these years why
have I gone to 10,000 airports in my
[__] life trying to find fulfilment
and we have a very full flight we'd like
to welcome our diamond medallion members
anything like why my life so much of it
has been that
when all you need to do is find love and
have a couple of kids and get a burger
and that's just the coolest [__]
thing you could ever [__] do and I and
I felt that and I knew it and I
understood it and I was just like yeah
this is what life is all about and
within an hour of that I was screaming
at a smoke detector calling it a [__]
and right there you you start to
understand what it's like for my poll
life to live with me I mean you have no
idea what's gonna Emmy is it gonna be
like [__] a Disney movie tonight are
we gonna be watching the [__] Manson
murders you know when I try to hide
behind labels so I'm passionate you know
I I care too much [__] lunatic I
yelled I got it you [__] [__]
at a goddamn smoke detector but that's
who I am
so considering that's who I am where the
[__] do I get off making fun of [__]
Donald Trump the way I have been lately
you know let her you know what it really
is with that guy it's not the politics
as much as it's I just don't like
bullies I just don't like bullies my
Nana but all the way back to when they
will kick it somebody started heckling
during her speech you know I mean and
which never works because they always
tossed the person out and that's it so
as they were kicking away he's like yeah
I get him out of here then he goes take
his coat check his Co you know that's
just like he was like yelling like he
was doing it it's like you have security
that they're handling your fight for you
stop back on like you're tough you know
and then I gotta tell you one of the
lowest [__] moments ever is like
during the middle of all of these
protests which are totally just and I
think are going to be really be a
positive thing for everybody he hides in
the basement
and then tweets about it he's so [__]
self-involved he thought people were
gonna care like oh no he turned the
lights it's just mind me like that
[__] on Halloween who doesn't want to
[__] participate and just shuts the
lights off and doesn't give out any
candy whatsoever
you know bizarre bizarre human being I
don't give a [__] about anybody else in
his cabinet I have no problem with any
of them I don't know [__] about politics
but like that type of [__] I just equate
it to sports the chips are down
do you [__] man up and drive the team
down the field you know or do you start
going Ryan Leaf and start screaming at
reporters I loved when he was trying to
sign that document too and the woman in
the press is asking questions and he
Shuster and then he asked she course
asks a question that he can't answer he
can't answer any question it doesn't
stop answering they just goes you know
you really something else you know that
it's like what does that even mean so
anyway I don't have a problem with the
Republican president you know if that
happens in November I just don't want it
to be that guy you know what I mean and
I just wish the [__] Democrats could
give you a goddamn choice is supposed to
this [__] guy I just feel like he
should be out bird-watching or something
is that what this country needs
you know [__] two eighty year old
guys going at it man I will tell you one
of the great photo ops I've ever seen is
him standing there with a scowl on his
face holding a [__] Bible up in front
of a church I don't even know what
there's some Jesus freaks out there can
you tell me what the [__] that even
meant I have no idea what did that even
mean it was [__] bizarre it felt like
the beginning of like one of those when
I first got cable like one of those
movies like the dead zone or the almond
like like they would have like the guy
playing the president the birds are away
of gentlemen you know Martin Sheen just
doing this crazy [__] behavior like
the big thing where you'd be like oh my
god keep manager the person in power is
just [__] nuts you know not saying
that the people
that we've had before him haven't all
been their own the sort of brand of
crazy slash war criminals like the last
two or three of them you don't I mean I
mean you get caught getting a blow job
so you bomb another country I mean
that's that's kind of uh you know Jesus
Christ you imagine brushing your teeth
thinking about that two [__] 20 years
later I don't know why I did that that's
gonna be an awkward conversation at some
point anyway but I think I am actually
very positive about all of this stuff I
think something really good is going to
come out of I think it was great that
the protesters went to white
neighborhoods and they didn't do any
[__] damage and I have the ability to
separate protesters from looters they're
not the same [__] people any more
than if you just look at you know some
middle-aged white guy you know he sees
supports Trump it's like not everybody
sports him not everybody supports the
Obama there's all different kinds of
[__] people
and I think yeah and I don't think all
cops are bad I just think there's like a
whatever whatever the percentage is just
get those people out and let's try some
sort of different approach you know like
I said you get a guy face down he's
handcuffed it's a wrap it's over he's no
longer a [__] threat it has to stop
there but like I don't think stopping
there and dangers any police officers
life because I'm trying to you know the
little I know about that job it's a
[__] unbelievably dangerous [__]
job that I think is easy to criticize
but sometimes there are situations where
they're in the wrong and this was one of
them so I hope that they fix it there
you go how was that was that nice enough
for everybody that's not gonna cause you
to get on your bicycle and [__] dress
like Greg LeMond didn't [__] run
after a couple of preteens
Oh God even if you agree with him if
you're his friend what do you say what
do you say depends on what he says you
know when you go down to bail him out or
whatever if he was just dialing hey you
know I could let my emotions get the
best of me my [__] shorts were too
tight and I just [__] I lost it I
felt like I couldn't breathe with my
[__] my compression suit you know
that I was wearing I don't know I just
sorta ly had that helmet on I felt like
a superhero it was hard to run on my
[__] bicycle clogs if he comes out
like that then you gotta beg alright man
he had a bad one I yelled at a smoke
detector you ripped some paper on I mean
cuz let's be honest like wouldn't you
talk about assault he just basically
tore the paper out of her [__] hand I
mean you know did he really hurt
somebody I'm sure he scared him I mean
he can't have people doing that but
let's let's take it down a little bit he
assaulted a 13 oh that's really broad
you know my mother assaulted all of us I
can tell you I in an old school my
mother yeah yeah she [__] yeah and
you know what we deserved it and I don't
feel like I'm institutionalized either
when I go back and I think of some of
the [__] [__] that we were doing yeah
I told you this [__] right my dad was in
a fraternity and he saved the paddle so
she used to use that on us since you
just line us all up I remember her mom
hit me with a wooden spoon I got my I
got my four I'm up and it [__] broke
before it hit me in the head but it's
just like that's just what was done it
what was whoo it was what was done there
was no self help you know there was
polio there was the Great Depression
this is what all my ancestors came up
from there wasn't time you meet what if
there was problems you had the [__]
you know nip it in the bud or nip it in
the butt what is that expression is it
nip it in the butt or in the bud never
know it's like a flower or like you like
[__] kick its ass nip it in the it is
bud origin all right nips
something in the bud means to stop it in
an early stage of its development Oh
before it can mature the phrase first
appeared in print as far as we know in
the late 16th century with bloom bloom
standing for standing in for bud
alright nip it in the bud or the but
incorrect version is nip it in the butt
okay there's another one that I said
wrong for a long [__] time I just
can't remember what the hell it was
basically I'm an idiot you know what I
mean okay and I did do a smoke alarm
what that fatty did to the [__] eye
don't you think he's that fat for a 60
year old you know I would love to have
that guy in this podcast and just be
like dude you know you want let's go
back and forth and just let's just trade
stories about losing your temper and
then doing or saying things that you
wish you could take back you know and
just have like a competition I bet I
could hang with that guy for at least 90
minutes I gotta tell that is pretty
crazy though to get off your bike I mean
I would he must have been on his bike
thinking about that [__] thinking about
it well maybe he just lost an argument
about that topic I mean I [__] guy he
went in 60 years old I mean say what you
want about him assaulting teenage girls
all right if you take that off the table
you got to admire the guys fire I want
to know what supplement he's using you
know I barely give a [__] about anything
and I'm only 52 on Wednesday this case
I'm talking about him like he's Old Man
Winter the guy could be my [__] older
brother oh my god anyway I would like to
think that by the time I'm 60 I like
people hanging up pieces of paper in a
park wouldn't bug me now if they were
taking him down and throwing him around
that would bug me but I still wouldn't
stop
I just muttered to myself [__]
[__] [__]
anyways I just I don't know this is my
deal I I'm not into politics I just
[__] hate bullies I just I can't
stand that [__] I've been guilty of it
okay before he start [__] pointing
out my shortcomings I know I've done it
I just [__] I don't like that [__]
alright CBD CBD MD one of my favorite
things to say CBD MD as a leader in the
CBD industry ce b d md Charlie Bravo
Delta Mike Delta is committed to
providing you with high quality THC free
CBD oil products I'm already in I don't
know what this stuff does whether you're
gunning for a raise or an Olympic gold
medal you need to stay at the top of
your game everyone from weekend warriors
to pros like Bubba Watson
I love Bubba Watson he bought the
General Lee after he won the Masters how
can you hate that guy Steve Smith senior
and Jorge Maz Maz Vidal so I don't know
Steve Smith is he wide receiver Jorge
Masvidal what does he do see a
motorcycle racer boxer huh how come you
didn't get scientist hang on a second
let me look this up here because there's
no famous scientists anymore maybe
that's why back in the day man you could
get some ass and curing a disease right
cuz they named it after you but now all
these scientists everything you know
they sign these contracts oh that's that
guy from the UFC oh my god with that
flying knee oh my god he redefined the
right there Fred Jesus Christ is that
guy a good fighter the most dangerous
[__] dude you're ever gonna run into
by the way did anybody anybody watch the
UFC this past weekend I watched it I
watched it that was a hard fight to
watch with what's-her-face there why
can't I remember anybody's [__] names
she's the greatest [__] female
fighter ever she's beat everybody and
knocked him out as Joe Rogan said beat
all the best and knocked him
what the [__] is her name UFC oh there's
another one this week
UFC 250 that was the one that I watched
for fucksakes amanda Nunez fought
Felicia Spencer and I watched that fight
and that was this one of those ones
where it's just like somebody gonna stop
this fight she just what the [__] am I
doing here so the suppose be an ad read
everyone from weekend warriors like pros
like Bubba Watson Steve Smith senior and
Jorge Maz Vidal Jesus up everybody you
don't have mispronounced that name trust
CB DMD to give them the natural support
and relief they need to reach their
goals and with so many world-class
professional athletes turning to CB DMD
you can be sure you're getting a safe
clean product from what the [__]
tinctures TI n si tu re s to topicals
how the [__] when you get through this
coffee if I'm gonna be this dumb ti NCT
u re Pro pronunciation teacher teacher
teacher tincture how do you like your
teacher this grade tincture what the
[__] is it tincture I'm gonna start this
read over again what is it what is it
cannabis tincture is 101 how to make how
to consume what is a tincture how does
it work medication made by dissolving
cannabis and alcohol also known as
golden or green dragon tincture Wow
alright let's take let's do take -
alright alright this pretend you didn't
hear that whole first read alright
everybody it's time for the take - it's
time for the podcast reads everybody CBD
MD as a leader in the CBD industry CBD
MD
committed to providing you with
high-quality THC free CBD oil products
whether you're gunning for a raise or an
Olympic gold medal you need to stay at
the top of your game
everyone from weekend warriors to pros
like Bubba Watson Steve Smith and UFC
great Jorge Masvidal trust CBD MD to
give them the natural support and relief
they need to reach their goals and with
so many world-class professional
athletes turning to CBD md you can be
sure you're getting safe clean for us a
safe clean product from teachers to
topicals - bath bombs and even pet
products they've got something for you
talk about your personal experience with
our products oh I rub it on my shoe
makes it feel great and that's actually
I think why I'm finally turning the
corner with my rotator cuff injury to
make it even easier to discover the
potential of CBD for yourself
CBD MD is offering my listeners 20% off
your purchases purchases when you are
purchased when you use the promo code
birbee you are are a checkout once again
that CBD MD com promo code burr for 2
percent off your order of premium CBD
oil products from CBD MD all right
policy genius you know people with
everything going on right now a lot of
people are asking if it's even possible
to buy life insurance at all the short
term answer is yes you can buy life
insurance during a pandemic and if you
have loved ones depending on your income
you probably should as an insurance
marketplace policy genius what as an
insurance marketplace policy genius is
in contact with life insurance companies
on their platform every day they're
there keeping track of all the changes
in the market so you don't have to which
means they can get you covered quickly
and for the best price here's how it
works policy genius compares quotes from
the top life insurance companies in one
place it takes just a few minutes to
compare quotes from the top insurers to
find your best price this doesn't just
save a lot of legwork
you could also say 1500 bucks or more a
year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and red tape for free so if
you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll be there to
take care of everything so if you're one
of the many people looking for to buy
life insurance right now but you're not
sure where to start head over to policy
genius com policy Jesus will help find
you the best rate and handle the process
completely they'll get to you and your
they'll get you and your family
protected and hopefully give you one
less thing to worry about all right
there we go see that how much better was
that second read wasn't it a lot better
I like to think it was a lot better all
right now I'm gonna get trashed by all
these people because I said I was gonna
change a couple outlets in my house ok
electricity all right do not do your own
electrical work you [__] period ok
thanks for the tip here's another tip
for electric outlets hey Bill this is a
pretty bare-bones email so I'll just get
right to the point
when you replace an outlet you have to
be careful which direction you twist the
wire the goal is to twist the wire in
the direction that the screws twists
when tightening if you're looking at the
back of the outlet you want to twist the
right side down and twist the right side
up that doesn't make sense the right
side down and the right side up this way
when you're starting you start
tightening the screw the twist and the
wire doesn't start coming undone it's a
small tip but can help you out
tremendously thanks for the MMP and
congratulations on kid number two thank
you I am thankful for both of those to
be honest with you I don't think I'm
gonna do the outlets only because if I
were to ever cause a fire god for
[__] bid even if we did get out of
the house from the relentless smoke
detectors it probably then wouldn't work
I burned down my [__] house and they
they would fight they would somehow I
don't know how firemen do this you know
they always find the cause of
[__] fire it's like isn't like what
caused the fire
on fire wasn't that the beginning of the
fire so it would have been on the on
fire the most like how come my bedroom
doesn't exist anymore but you can find
this [__] outlet and the fact that it
wasn't wired properly you know they
always [__] find what it is and I get
that different things burn differently
right like obviously a piece of paper is
gonna be totally gone where is something
that's metal or something like that
might just be all charred up and [__]
like that but you know you can't start a
fire with something that isn't flammable
if you just take one match and then you
put it on a piece of paper and then
stick it underneath some [__] that's
already there that's flammable how do
they know it's stay and then you take
the match and walk away how do they find
it they did they figure it out what are
you rooting against the bill I don't
know what I'm saying alright tip for
electric outlets I just did that I would
love to do it because I have like five
or six outlets that are just you know
one works good and the other one doesn't
and I'm just [__] sick of it so you
know what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
I'm gonna buy all the outlets and then
I'm gonna have an electrician do it
alright so everybody can [__] relax
and then once again I'll pay for
something that I probably could have
done by myself all right
bankers dear Billy banker [__] I'm a 21
year old college student majoring in
finance or as you would say future
banker [__] yes I don't think you're a
[__] yet but you what's gonna happen is
you're gonna get involved in that game
and you either play ball or you get
wacked when you ran about greedy bankers
who at the banks are you referring to
tellers security IT board members and is
it all banks are there any in particular
you aren't a fan of I think banks are
great they loan money to students for
college small businesses and make homes
and car purchase as possible without
banks this stuff wouldn't be possible
for people with pockets not as deep as
yours
that money you have rightfully earned
average American can't write a check for
that stuff I know you complain about
interest rates being too high interest
is determined and how likely the person
taking the loan will be able to pay back
the loan pay the loan back more risks to
the bank means higher interest just like
with in any investment you and I make we
want more reward from more risk we take
doesn't this kid just sound like a
college student you're basically
explaining banking to me that if it's
done properly this is how it works at
any point during this email you can
allude to what the [__] they did for
over 40 to 50 years to gradually get
themselves completely deregulated so we
had that what happened in 2008 and the
[__] bubble that they're now creating
again with these [__] high-rise
luxury apartments that's all of our
money what about that what about the
fact that back in the day when they were
regulated I forget what it was but if
you'd if you deposited a thousand
dollars in they were only able to loan
out like thirty percent on a thousand or
something like that it was something of
a responsible number and then they just
kept going after these politicians and
paid him off and then eventually not
only could they loan out the entire
thousand they could loan off another
thousand dollars to two other people so
off your grand they could loan out three
grand so they basically counterfeited
two grand that's not even there and I
mean you combine it with the fact that
they then had these new rules that made
people who weren't qualified to get
homes to get homes which then drove up
the prices of the [__] houses you had
what happened in 2008 that's why I think
they're [__] and then after they [__]
everybody over and old people who
thought they had them their savings the
money that they earned then had to spend
the rest of their life [__] you know
eating dog food and these [__] [__]
at AIG then say that you know hey we're
too big to fail bail us out and then we
had to bail them out with money that we
now pay interest on that's why they're
[__] okay you just sitting here
explaining to me how in a perfect world
you know banking
operates I understand that all right
lastly he says if you keep your entire
life savings in a cash in cash in a bank
you are an idiot up to $250,000 is
federally insured per bank account that
money should be with a wealth management
company so the money can grow and be
safe thanks for listening and go [__]
yourself well listen buddy I will chalk
this up to the fact that you're a young
person and what she'll quickly realize
is that how the game works is they have
is you're gonna put your money in play
are they gonna take it and then when you
put it in play you're gonna be exposed
and they're gonna take it that way
that's basically how it is and you can
try to be conservative as you mean if I
keep my entire life savings in in in
cash in the bank I'm not an idiot for
doing that I'm an idiot because I
believe that the banks are it's actually
gonna be there but 250 grand if I live
my life correctly and off of interest in
whatever else and whatever I was still
earning if I just live within my means
then I am NOT an idiot I'm actually a
responsible citizen but this whole idea
that you know you can you can never have
enough money you have to keep putting it
out there is because our economy is a
[__] Ponzi scheme that's why and if
people start pulling out and they stop
playing the [__] game the whole thing
collapses so I would look up on that
alright Woodrow Wilson's letter of
regret the Federal Reserve all of that
type of [__] how the Federal Reserve is
actually a private bank a private
corporation I mean I went down that
rabbit hole I'm done with it because
nobody gives a [__] and we're all tied
into the lie but like you know I don't
know this is something that you want to
do so I don't want to [__] all over it
but you know if you read up on it you
know I've actually sat in banks talking
to people talking about how [__] up it
is and they get this look on their face
they're like yeah I know I know and I'm
like so what are you gonna do you're
doing gold coins they're like yeah I do
a little bit of that they're even
hedging their bets but I just look at it
like you know by the time this person
figured out what they were getting
involved in they
already had a major in that and [__]
college loans and they were already
running on the wheel but I might be
wrong I could be wrong about all this I
hope I am
I hope banks are the way that you said
they are has not been my experience from
the little that I know my girlfriend is
racist against me um hi bill I've been
dating this girl for a year she is Asian
American I am half Caucasian and half
Hispanic but I look white she was
telling me it's funny that I'm half
Hispanic because her Hispanic friend
objected to her dating me when I thought
I was just white normally I wouldn't let
this bother me because part of me gets
it all people of Carla have experienced
some sort of racism from white people
the conversation made me uncomfortable
and she must have picked up on it
because she started defending her friend
all right you said normally I wouldn't
let this bother me because I get it all
right but it did bother you because I
guess you like this girl that she's
saying this [__]
she began bashing white people in
explaining to me that I'm one of the
good ones
I come from a liberal mixed family I
said that even though I get it I still
don't think that they should assume
conservative races just because I'm
white she began to lecture me about
white privilege and how racism against
White's isn't the same as racism against
people of color which I agree with but
does that make it okay
I will never truly understand they're
basically arguing because they're not in
a position of power where their racism
can affect you getting a job or not
getting a job it can't affect you if
you're walking in a park at night and
they decide to jump you but other than
that white racism as the theory goes and
it's presented holds way more power
because they can actually end your
[__] dreams which I love when white
people then it's try to explain to
people who aren't white that that's not
the case
let me explain your experience although
people who aren't white explain white
people to white people it's just what
people
though everybody knows everything I
think you haven't you learned that in
the pandemic somebody said to me the
other day because like the amount of
people without medical degrees telling
me how to avoid getting the corona virus
we're all full of [__] okay and I am too
I yelled at a smoke I called a smoke
detector a [__] people all right I will
never truly understand their experiences
I know that but at what point are they
being hypocritical the fair question I
understand that I understand that I've
been in this situation it made me think
of when Dorothy lands in Oz and they
want to know if she's a bad witch or a
good witch and she's like I'm not a wish
which I'm just a kid from Kansas this
isn't the first time I've had to
establish that I'm one of the good ones
I assume you and Nia have been through
the same thing oh we [__] argue all
the time about [__] like this it's
actually it could be a show like we have
and then in the end I I usually end up
like being able to explain myself in a
way that she understands and she's able
to explain her way in a way that she
understands this is basically deal as
long as me and my wife don't watch the
news we get along great do I just keep
trying to prove that I'm one of the good
ones now do I call around on her book
hypocrisy both do I let it go I don't
know any well what I usually say when
people do that it's like you know I just
go you know you sound like a white
person and then I also tell them when
they try to hit me with that this white
people are just inherently evil it's
like no what you're seeing is any race
of people with unchecked power that's
what happens is eventually you know I
don't know what it is it is a
fascinating thing where I feel like
people that crave power and then their
psychological makeup is an interesting
thing because I don't know most people I
know that are cool are not into wanting
to control [__] and people who aren't
controlling people are not cool
to be around but then having said that
somebody has to lead the herd so I don't
know I I don't I get this weird point my
life where I I just feel like I don't
know [__] know anything anymore he
says I don't know anymore I don't want
to be one of those white people trying
to act like they're equally victimized
no you never want to do that that's a
bad look because of their skin color
like yeah you could go standard yeah
mine is getting choked to death by a cop
other than that yeah exactly - the
slavery and all of that [__] and all
the [__] [__] that's actually in your
head that you don't even [__] address
to other people other than that yeah
it's the exact same [__] experience
yeah but having said that there's only
so much of that horseshit that you can
[__] listen to you know what I mean
that's like when I listen like when
white female comics start [__]
complaining you know about how you can
listen to it you're like okay I get it I
get to a [__] point and then it just
gets the point of being like you know
not for nothing you're kind of further
in your career than I was when I was at
your you know when I was doing it for
five years so I mean I think the fact
that you are a woman makes you stand out
it's actually kind of helping you more
than it's hurting you am I crazy here
but I know that that's not how it works
with white women white women are the
victims victim don't get me stuck it
started with that [__] I had a great bit
back in the day when I did stand up
about how white women how they [__]
is incredibly how they sidestepped their
own white privilege just dumped it all
on white guys [__] unbelievable
stroke of genius and then stuck
themselves at the front of the line as
far as you know people speaking out
about being oppressed it's it was
amazing all right with that I'll stop
doing parts of my act that I can't even
remember anymore all right how music got
ruined in the 2000s yo Billy research a
few months ago you talked about a video
of Rick Beato Beato he had that video
about drums and how they were edited to
be perfect and Moe
songs are recorded with the click track
while highlighting the genius of bonham
strumming yeah it was a great video
anyways he just put out a video and
talks about producing music in the mm
how a and our guys would sign anyone
with a decent lead singer paying less
attention to the band he talks about how
he played on a lot of tracks when a band
member couldn't
thinking back I hadn't realized how bad
those bands were lots of new metal as
the genre was called he's got a great
channel and educates on music a lot yeah
I'll have to check that out but as far
as my understanding you know there's a
lot of people especially in pop music
there was a whole there was that whole
group of musicians out here they did a
documentary on it the Wrecking Crew and
I particularly remember the woman that
played bass and she just like I mean she
like 200 number-one hits or something
she played on something [__] insane
and they would come up and they would
have like basically these chord
progressions and then this the studio
musicians would fix them and they didn't
get any songwriting credit of course
because I could tell by the houses that
they lived in when they were sitting
there you know telling their stories
they all had very like modest [__]
houses and whenever you go to the
[__] you know the executive of the
record label he's got like the infinity
pool in the background you know the
Botox wife I saw some of the other day
in the ghost zone with the whole Botox
face and it it's literally like it looks
like my passport picture which I should
show you guys I have like when they took
the picture the shine off of my head
ended up [__] with my passport
picture where it looks like there's a
chunk of my head missing and I gotta
take you to the city hall just like this
is okay like I'm gonna like travel to do
stand-up and God knows where some other
country I'm gonna give them this and
they're gonna be alright with this and
then I got this passport ID and were
they just like hyper zoomed in on my
face or you can see basically from my
eye
Brow's down to just below my bottom lip
and he can't see the rest of my head I'm
like this looks like it doesn't even fit
I was gonna go over there I just I just
don't have the time well I you know what
happened - pandemic happen so anyway
that's plow head speaking of drums in
that [__] I actually sat down yesterday
the first time since my wonderful son
was born and I played a little bit of
drums and was the first time I just sat
down and played and wasn't trying to do
that bottom lick or whatever the [__] I
was trying to figure out hey I was the
best I played since the pandemic started
I was like I'm gonna learn how to do
this and this you know and it was the
most fun I had I came out of my little
drum room like just [__] t-shirts
soaking wet I just I had a [__] blast
and my bass drum foot was faster than it
ever been cuz I just completely didn't
give a [__] and I was just playing along
to [__] everything and then I always
you know when I do like try to get back
at warming up and trying to get back
into shape I always end up going to Guns
& Roses Appetite for Destruction I play
the whole first side and I dove every
time I listen to when I hear another
little thing that Steven Adler did a
little high hat little quick little bark
thing or something that he'll do like on
the ride cymbal like in the Bell just
one little taste another little tasty
thing that he did or maybe understand
like his drums within the whole
composition of the song more like wow
like how did he come up with that part
he's just a [__] genius man anyways
deep cuts this is one of my favorite
things that we've ever done here on the
podcast and I've been looking up all
these songs he's been great great great
suggestions here all right all right hey
Oh Billy b-side wanted to let you know
about these awesome but not often talked
about tracks in case you don't really
know of them I'm sure I don't there's so
much great music out there it's there's
no way to know all of it obviously
alright Black Sabbath
Johnny blade was this when Ronnie James
was in the band this this song is from
there
last album with Ozzy alright there's the
answer in 1978 and never gets the
attention it deserves I'll already like
the name of it it begins with a
long-winded synth intro but then Bill
Ward starts rolling along with a riff on
his snare Ozzy comes in and starts
singing about a knife-wielding character
that could have been in a Scorsese
Scorsese movie they go through two
choruses before they break it down at
2:28 and - one of the best and heaviest
riffs Tom Tom Tony Iommi ever wrote and
Bill Ward plays a huge Bonham s beat to
it if you put this part on during a
circus the elephants would start
stomping the [__] to pieces the song
picks up tempo again and the last minute
and a half is an epic guitar solo that
Tony Iommi takes all over the place
alright I'm in on that Genesis behind
the lines when Genesis was still
straddling the line between Prague and
pop they put out the Duke album in 1980
the song starts this song starts it off
behind the lines and right out of the
gate it's a showcase of how I'm for how
amazing of a drummer Phil Collins is oh
he's one of the greatest drummers ever
doesn't get the credit because people
look at him like a frontman
the drums have a huge clear sound and
they drive this song along with the
prominent synth riff in the forefront if
you pay close attention you hear Phil
doing what's some really invented but
some really interesting one-handed fills
on the Tom's while he's working the ride
and as always he's throwing in accents
and things nobody else would have ever
thought to do that show why he's one of
the greatest drummers of all time it's
incredibly fun to play along - I think
I'm gonna go right to [__] iTunes
here and download this [__] lastly but
not leastly yes going for the one I
wouldn't know where to begin describing
what kind of music this song is but it's
so amazing maybe prog rock honky-tonk
I'm not gonna lie to you that sounds
horrific but I'll listen to it I've
never heard anything like it every
instrument has played to such a high
level of skill but not in a look at me
shred a thousand notes kind of way
guitarist Steve Howe takes his pedals
his pedal steel for a steel pedal I
think it would meant to say for a crazy
ride while bassist Chris Squire sounds
like he's going up and down stairs with
his note Allen was something I'm
literally a music critic wrote this
Allen white on the drums is driving the
whole thing and Rick Wakemans since and
piano adds so much on top of it all John
Anderson's high nutless voice is an
acquired taste but he sings so
powerfully and chooses such cool
melodies that win you over the song
builds with intensity until it's almost
too much but then suddenly it breaks
open with the with goose bump inducing
keychains and keychain as they sing love
over and over again but it's like you
were on a rocket blasting through space
and suddenly bursts through a stormy
atmosphere to arrive at a utopian planet
well worth the write anyway check them
out when you get a chance and sincere
congratulations on your baby boy oh
thank you so much all right we're going
a little heavy these deep cuts I'm
loving about these we're going really
heavy with the rock specifically the
white rock anybody got like deep cuts on
any sort of rap any black music country
music whatever you got anybody over
there in Asia or Europe whatever you got
let me know let me know all right that's
gonna be the podcast here um stop
watching the news get off social media
unless you're you know promoting the
movie and the the cartoon I have coming
out this week cuz it's all about me
people it's not about defending 13 year
olds hanging up leaflets in a park it's
not about that it's not about portly
[__] 60 year old bike riders those
dumb [__] so why do you need those
shoes can I look that up before I sign
off here I just what what is the
advantage of those stupid bike shoes
your feet don't slip out of the [__]
pedals it's like how fast are you
pedaling why don't you [__] go into a
higher gear you dumb [__]
why are bike racing shoes
connected to pedals monitors secondly
designed to work with the clipless pedal
system such system temporarily connect
the shoe in the pedal like a ski binding
ba-ba-ba-ba do you need special pedals
this is what I really was that pedal
compatibly and why do you need these
does it really okay clipless bike shoes
do they make you go faster clipless bike
shoes necessary or stupid ok clipless
pedals really required I mean really all
right here we go this is this is the
tone I was looking for I use flat pedals
always have I am extremely fit and I'm
confident that even on a light hybrid
commuter I can beat the most amateurs
all right this guy's talking [__] right
out of the gate not to sound like a jerk
that's just how it saves I have a racer
full carbon only had it a month I hear
somebody some people say there's no
point of a road bike without clipless
which i think is a stupid comet as it
doesn't make sense I can get I can get
the point where efficiency can be lost
but it does not necessarily mean surely
that my ride speed power etc will be
less than other people a ride is more
complicated than pedals and my
understanding of athletics events is
that generally about 70% is metal and
the rest is physics is physical or
mental sorry
alright this person says they make a
huge difference in simple terms you can
apply more power more more of the time
essential to your whipping motion on the
bottom of the stroke oh so I see so when
the pedals coming back up there's that
moment where your foot would come off
the pedal this keeps it on it more so
you're actually and then you're actually
able to pull it up
you know what that makes sense look
at--that's I stand corrected so god
bless that sixty-year-old assaulting
those children oh what a world
all right everybody go [__] yourselves
have a great couple of days then I'll
check on Thursday don't forget June 12th
I need you guys seriously not [__]
around please watch the king of Staten
Island and season 4th f is for family
all right that's it I'll see you
you